get a mentor
today i'm answering a question from one
of my youtube viewers taylor love you
guys
taylor is 15 years old wants to start a
company
in the energy business but just wants to
basically sell the idea it doesn't have
the money doesn't have the funds and
have the experience to go out and get
the patents
and the expertise to kind of launch that
and sell it and one of my advice how
does how does
how to get started how do you do this
how do you sell your idea when you're 15
years old you don't have any resources
or connections
my best advice here is go
get a mentor you need somebody to help
show you the ropes here
you need the patent you're going to need
the patent you go out and you talk to an
energy company
they're going to say do you have the
patent if not then they're going to go
do it themselves the
they're going to screw you out of your
idea that why do they want to pay you
millions of dollars when they can just
shortcut it and do it themselves
it's only because you have the patent
but what i would suggest you do is go
find somebody who has done this a couple
times
go find somebody who's close to you
ideally in your city
who has created some patents and license
some technology to companies
and go learn from them work with them
and tell your story listen there aren't
that many
15 year olds who are who are go-getters
like you i don't get that many 15 year
olds right into me
with business ideas and wanting some
advice your enthusiasm
is infectious people want to give back
people want to help
what i would suggest for you to do is go
find somebody who's done it
ask them for coffee ask to meet with
them tell them about your idea
and maybe you co-patent your first idea
maybe you co-patent your next five ideas
together
but there's somebody showing you the
ropes because you're going to learn
so much more by working with them and
commercializing an idea
than just trying to figure it all out
yourself and getting frustrated that
you're not making progress
the easiest way to learn something is to
work with somebody who's already done it
before
and for them to show you the ropes
instead of you trying to figure
everything out yourself
in my first business one of my mentors
was a man named john
who had a tremendous impact on our
business and
showed me how to sell a product and to
market yourself and how to behave in a
in a meeting and how to create
excitement and energy
and i took that with me to my future
businesses
even this so for those of you guys
watching if you've been a loyal viewer
of my youtube channel
you go back two years ago and you look
at my older videos and the content may
be great but my delivery sucked like
i look at that like ah man those videos
are so bad
they're way better now why because i'm
working with a mentor
jenny she coaches me we have weekly
sessions i
i talked with her for an hour before i
got in front of the camera today
and started recording these videos and
her advice and her wisdom and her
experience
that she spent her whole life
accumulating
is quickly transferred to me and i could
pick it up in a short amount of time and
see
huge improvements things that i may not
have been able to ever figure out on my
own
or if it did it'll take years and years
and years and years and years so she
shortcuts my path
my path to learning my path to success
and that's really what you need right
now
you need to find somebody who's done it
who's taken ideas
patented them sold them commercialized
them licensed them
and work with them learn from them and
just start it off simple
do your research find the people ask for
coffee see who you connect with
see who you have a relationship with
because people like giving back
if the student is genuinely interested
if the student
is taking those lessons and
and applying them there's a such a great
feeling
such such a huge high you get when
you're helping somebody out and you help
them
accomplish their goals and you see their
face light up and you
you get enthusiasm and energy from them
but there's also nothing worse than
giving advice to somebody really trying
to help them out
and they're lazy and lackadaisical and
they don't care they don't take your
advice
people don't want to be in that kind of
relationship so go
find your mentor and get started believe
for those of you watching like the video
you can subscribe to the channel
see more videos just like this thank you
so much i'll see you soon